[Musik]
auf ein extrem spannender bis centrica
und zwar von a bis z
nicht einfach irgendwo ihre großväter
und halter des wtc sondern vor
arbeitszeit bisher gestalten und das
nach meinen vorstellungen möglichst
kraft möglich vermittler
thomas wegler baut in peru kaffee an mit
erfolg seine kaffeebohnen werden
weltweit mit bestnoten ausgezeichnet
[Musik]
finanziell trägt sein unternehmen noch
keine großen früchte trotzdem teilt er
seinen erfolg mit den einheimischen
was treibt ihn an davon handelt dieser
film
[Musik]
ich passiere endlose schotterwege um
thomas wegler zu gelangen
von lima auf auf 5000 meter über die
anden runter richtung amazonasbecken 15
stunden dauert es bis sich in georgia
may einem der entlegensten flecken perus
ankomme auf schweglers fahren
der 44 jährige kam zufällig zum kaffee
2005 reiste er für eine non profit
organisation nach südamerika er
unterstützte eine kaffee kooperative
dann wurde er kaffeehändler vor sieben
jahren entschieden sich selber café
anzupflanzen qualität störe dass so ein
fan ruft bauer
das könnte so schön blüht das riesenhaus
ausländer und realität ist nicht so was
ist was mir alles in menschen
investieren sind erst am anfang
er produziert fairtrade-kaffee beliefert
unter anderem ein schweizer luxus
kaufhaus und eine hotelkette
[Musik]
das sagen hier hat allerdings nicht
schwegler sondern seine peruanische frau
gisela
[Musik]
der kaffee ist sie trocken er wirkte
zwischen 11 und 13 sein
er hat 93 er ist sehr trocken
wir lagern ihnen das feuchtigkeit
aufnehmen kann
bis er auf 11 ist
die farm von skis ella und thomas
wickler ist gleichzeitig auch ihr
zuhause
hier leben sie zusammen mit einem teil
der angestellten sowie zehn hunden
[Musik]
schwegler ist für den handel zuständig
die internetverbindung ist miserabel
dass abwickele geschäfte deshalb mühsam
besonders wenn wie jüngst eine ladung
café verschwindet
[Musik]
und dann habe ich dann irgendwann mal um
solche konten auf dem schiff ist muss
zwei tonnen kokain gefunden hand als
eins der größten fund und mit dem
schritt war schon mal ein ähnlicher fall
hatte und tags sind sind auf diesem
niveau
und während zurück kann jetzt gmail über
das kaufhaus wohnen in bremerhaven ist
und dann kann ich endlich kunden
beliefere die hälfte des jahres
verbringt er in der schweiz
seine frau ist immer hier deshalb
besitzen sie so viele hunde die geben
ihr ein gefühl von sicherheit
im dorf höre ich nur positives über
schwedler er setzte sich immer wieder
für die region ein
[Musik]
ist georgia - eine neue heimat geworden
2012 anfangen und das hat zum teil noch
kein nachbar inzwischen abgelöst wird
der kaffee aber bringen und war robbies
erschafft und innere gemeinschaft lebt
dann wird das schon heimat drin
linz große begriff habe ich immer gern
ihm ist wichtig dass die einheimischen
von seinem erfolg profitieren
als nächstes will schwägler eine neue
schule bauen
dafür macht er werbung keine schule
wir haben ferien kommt auch zum treffen
heute um 17 uhr in der schule ja es ist
schon verteilt perfekt
nein
hermia pachauris ist die besitzerin des
dorfladens der zugleich auch ihre
wohnung ist
ich mache gerne brot aber es ist viel
arbeit mit holz zu feiern
ich träume von einem gas oder elektro
ofen für meine kinder wünsche ich mir
dass sie einmal studieren dass sie
vorwärts kommen und etwas aus ihrem
leben machen können nicht alle denken
sowie die fünffache mutter erzählt mir
schwegler fehlen hand vor dem thema
bildung angestellten sind abschnitte
arbeiten sind ohne dass statt am
studieren und das weckt er dann als auch
die angst also dass die noch reich sind
zuschauern altersvorsorge kind sorgen
david älteren wildenten mit der ahv
es sei nicht primär entwicklungshelfer
betont er immer wieder sondern
geschäftsmann sein fokus liege beim
aufbau seiner kaffeemarke
[Musik]
gerade wird die süße der kaffee wären
geprüft denn lied hat auch hier seine
frau
der wird ist sehr hoch 23 briggs sie hat
der chef gesagt wir sind werfer
sie hat sehr gut mit dem lüd ungar und
harte linie
ich bin teamplayer und ein peru ist für
peruanerin einfacher blitz führer für bb
für den schweizer kennengelernt haben
sie sich 2008 in einem club in lima gar
nicht schlecht er war ein bisschen
anstrengend anfangs hat er mir nicht
besonders gefallen war ein freund eines
freundes
wir haben ein bisschen geredet aber
verstanden haben wir uns nicht zurück
nach ein paar mal treffen haben wir uns
verliebt
ich und mein thomas mit den blauen augen
wirst du nicht 32 oder 3 die frage ist
wann
[Musik]
kinder müssen warten
der aufbau der firma hält sie zu sehr
auf trab
[Musik]
die straßen erschweren die arbeit immens
er zeigt mir eine die während der
regenzeit glitschig sei wie seife
durch diese kilo grottenhof kurve road
to go korrigiere pflicht aufwärts
kostendruck vorhin gott 10 mx sitzen
aber gott sehr steil glaubt man nur
durch ein bremsmanöver gestört
er will den verantwortlichen für
straßenbau der region von einer
sanierung überzeugen
an geld fehle es der region nicht aber
korruption seien peru ein großes thema
wir fahren zum straßenbau
verantwortlichen wo dieser wohnt weiß
schwegler nicht genau
ich suche herrn edgar montes und weiter
oben was weiter oben fahren sie da hoch
dort ist sein haus st
wenn sie mit dem termin ab macht man
doch glatt termin ab dass das gibt's nur
traditionen hofgang zonen untergang
mitmachen
wir haben glück und finden ihn zusammen
mit seinem schwiegervater der berühmte
edgar montes wir haben sie überall
gesucht in der ganzen gegend gehen wir
rein und trinken kaffee
[Musik]
was sorgen macht ist der zugang zu
unserer fall auch unsere nachbarn die
familienpartei und cosman leiden unter
dem zustand der unterstützung beantragen
[Musik]
in der regenzeit können werden kaffee
nicht runter transportieren
letztes jahr hatten wir große verluste
deswegen bist du morgen zu hause ja
morgen gehe ich nach glos dann komme ich
vorbei einfach vor 16
schwegler will konkrete projekte
realisieren einfach geld zu spenden sei
reine symptombekämpfung könnten
sie produzieren will sie die
infrastruktur hans und cafés dollar
bringen
und dann hat sie in langfristige nutzer
tv teams nämlich und trafen may com hand
und du darfst dann mittelfristig besser
klappe hand oder mehr optionen
wir sehen uns morgen um 9
danke ich bin überrascht wie schnell sie
sich auf einen termin einigen
was dieser wert ist erfahre ich später
ich erlebe schwägler als sehr
engagierten schaffer diese eigenschaft
wird von den einheimischen geschätzt er
gibt jedem arbeit linken er ist wirklich
so er ist wirklich einfach ein gutes
nicht alle sehen in schwägler nur den
guten viele auch den goldesel
das erzählte mir seine frau als wir am
frühen abend richtung schule fahren
die menschen denken dass thomas und ich
reich sind
aber das sind wir wirklich nicht aber es
ist die mentalität der menschen die
sitzung heute ist deshalb wichtig wir
wollen klarstellen dass die neue schule
kein geschäft sondern etwas gutes für
die kinder ist für ihre zukunft die
menschen hier wollen sie versuchen
solche situationen auszunutzen und das
wollen wir nicht
die wände der schule sind durchnässt sie
kann jederzeit einstürzen
schwegler ist der initiator dieses
projekts seine firma finanziert einen
teil der neuen schule der andere teil
soll über spenden zusammenkommen
wir möchten wissen was eure erwartungen
und hoffnungen sind für die neue schule
wir bekommen von niemandem unterstützung
wenn ihr uns helfen können ziehen
gerücht sehr dankbar
zum treffen sind nur frauen und kinder
gekommen
angesprochen werden aber vor allem die
männer väter können helfen die schule zu
bauen wir bringen das geld hier packen
mit an
nur zusammen können wir etwas bewirken
thomas und ich sie nicht in der lage
löhne zu zahlen
das liegt nicht in unserer möglichkeiten
das projekt liegt der 33 jährigen am
herzen
sie kommt zwar aus einfachsten
verhältnissen konnte nur die grundschule
besuchen
als ich soll hier wird etwas benötigt
wollte ich etwas bewirken
die kinder sollen nicht das gleiche
erleben wie ich sie sollen das werden
was ich nie hatte
[Musik]
im regenwald herrscht bereits emsiges
treiben
nur bei schweglers geht es noch ruhig zu
und her
[Musik]
kommen stehe endlich auf aus diesem
schlauch kommt das einzige wasser
umgeleitet von bach während der
regenzeit ist es brauch in der nacht
wird schwegler oft von ratten geweckt
dass ein produzent von spitzenkaffees so
wohnt überrascht mich entschleunigen
wirklich zum leben in der schweiz
fokussiert dann wenn man weniger platz
liegt das restaurant internet sofern sie
wirklich bewerten sowie garten und das
tut es ist anstrengend und man konnte es
winkler studierte betriebsökonom ii und
baut ein internationales netzwerk von
prozenten importeuren exporteuren und
röstern auf jetzt ist der kaffee pharma
und zahlt sich pro monat 4000 franken
aus in der schweiz könnte er als
betriebsökonom ein vielfaches verdienen
an diesem morgen bekommen die arbeiter
ihr geld schwegler hat sein ganzes
erspartes in diese firma gesteckt und
zusammen mit investoren seinen traum von
einer eigenen café form realisiert
aber ich bin näher so ganz total dann
zusammen braucht vielleicht weil ich von
proben von der tour positive marktumfeld
zu fest glaubt dass es dass es
funktioniert was wir machen und es geht
immer lösungen
ich hoffe sehr schwierigen moment kommt
und weil man dann probier tresor 1
blieben das tor auf der anderen die tür
zum straßenprojekt bleibt heute wohl zu
genau das war ja als vierte fanny das
war natürlich absolut pünktlich zu
lernen und das war schließlich dass das
ist für den begriff der handelt den
organen schrieb sich nun der start am
morgen weiß nicht ob astana auf die
motorhaube und zu müssen wir dann noch
mal und das ganze 15 und 23 mal regen
mal startet ein sicher da
mit dieser hartnäckigkeit hat er schon
einiges erreicht
die gesamtqualität seines kaffees wird
mit bis zu 87 von 100 punkten eingestuft
er hat schon einige preise gewonnen
im café markt zu überleben seid trotzdem
ein kampf
willst du bruch von unserer man hier
noch mandarinen
auch soll einen anbau nein die haben wir
auch bekommen natürlich einmalig in peru
also wenn sie möglich meinte die hand
meistens merken sie womöglich weiß nicht
ich bin nicht ich sondern stritten
harmonischer man es gibt immer
situationen muss was nicht gut aber das
ist grillen argumente business märz war
wenn wir nicht ganz streitet das nicht
gelernt
ich habe immer ich bin immer gerne
tonnen aus und es gibt im geschäftsleben
immer wieder situationen wo einfach
entstand wo man sich missversteht wo man
sich bedroht gefühlt und dann wollen wir
mehr street wo man muss kämpfen dass man
früher war ich dachte ist ein er vor
hitze fast gestorben
hier ist die hose kaputt eine firma in
einem fremden land von 0 aufzubauen und
sich gleichzeitig für die region
einzusetzen
mich beeindruckt sein engagement das ist
wichtig für mich aber auch eine von der
walz und können sagen du hast in ganz
kleinen rahmen für können bis positiv
speed trage ich glaube manche sind sind
nur glücklich waren sie ausgeknipst
duschwanne andere leute bis mittragen
ich glaube alles andere ist nicht schön
und bequem probst eine langfristig
erfüllen
auch nicht in die zwiebel etwas macht
das gleich so nicht
[Musik]
die welt ein kleines stückchen besser
machen
das ist ihm zweifellos gelungen ich bin
gespannt wohin ihn sein weg noch führt
[Musik]
wo ist